so a reality show you guys said a very
brave thing
why did you decide to let us
very it's not reality it's a docu-series
because we have two realities
uh we decided to do it because our
relationship is a in a constant state of
healing
and in a process that's much greater
than ourselves and we have a man named
ted
who reminds us to take a look
at our part instead of focusing on the
other this is what i learned from ted
you're not responsible for what you
don't know
but once you do you are
he'll say to me what could you have done
better
i want to be
part of the healing
we've been together you know my whole
life and i can honestly say on the show
i learned things about you i never knew
i learned how to negotiate and be
proactive and not reactive i learned how
to love
honor and be reverent
even when disagreeing yeah we saw there
was a lot of
uh
difficulties in the relationship that
we're getting to see we're very honest
and candid i'm a different person than i
was when we started the show that's for
sure
and one thing i hope that happens for
other families is it makes them
challenge
their
their thoughts about their own family
or maybe even
how what how families are in general the
thing that i'm really proud of is that
winona and i
did our own personal work we call ted
our big toe
he helps us stand up and then go in the
right direction but
i'm enormously proud i'm terrified
because we didn't get creative control
or anything so we'll be seeing it so
it's very much reality it's unscripted
yeah it's unscripted and it is the good
bad and the ugly we wouldn't i will
speak for myself i wouldn't have done it
any other way though at this point in my
life i'm just kind of hoping that
um
i it holds me to my own journey and it
causes me to stay looking in the mirror
of truth for myself keeps us accountable
one final question because i gotta let
you guys go i know they're pulling you
strength of women that's what we're
talking about all tonight you did a very
strong thing in revealing your painful
childhood past ashley's done the same in
her book
and has been so brave because i know
that she's all three of us have because
the stuff she's saying is true
all the stuff in the book about her
unhappy childhood it's all true
i think it's key for us to
spend time figuring out our own reality
every unhappiness is tied to a story
and we have to go back and figure out
our stories and then it's our stories
and the veil has been lifted secrets
keep you sick and families will heal
once they get real
you